ERIC WOERNER: All right.
My name is Eric Woerner.
I'm the Director of Software
Architecture at Trustwave
and today we're going
to talk about migrating
Trustwave's large Customer
Portal over to Dart.
So some of the things
we'll cover today
as we're migrating
the UI that we
built within Flex over to Dart.
Similar to Workiva,
what they've done,
but we'll explain
our journey, and what
we've gotten to so far.
At first we'll talk a little
bit about who Trustwave
is as a company so you can
understand the services we
offer to our customers, and
what the portal framework does
today.
And then we'll get into
a little bit of why
we're migrating that this time.
Why is it a good time for
us to get off of Flex,
and start taking advantage
of Dart, and things
that it offers.
And as we go through
this journey,
there was four
fundamental things
that we wanted to
make sure that we
accomplished when we started
looking into this in Q4
last year.
And we'll find out by
the end of this talk,
and what you can discover
through our journey
is we have increased
productivity
with using Dart
Editor going forward.
We can still use RPC
style calls within Dart
for calling our
backend services.
We have Application Development
with Angular and Polymer UI
components for building
out our applications that
load into our portal.
And also, we wanted
to make sure that when
we started migrating to the new
portal framework within Dart
that we could still leverage
our Flex modules that we
load in today to the portal.
So let's get in a little bit
about who Trustwave is, and I
promise this next slide
is the only slide I got
from marketing, and so I'll go
through it pretty quick, so we
get through it.
Trustwave, they started as
a PCI compliance company.
And PCI stands for the
payment card industry,
and a set of controls
within a framework
to make sure that your
credit card information done
with companies that do credit
card payments is secure.
And through that we've
grown, and now we
have a portal-- an
on demand portal--
that offer services for threat,
vulnerability, and compliance
management to over 3 million
subscribers within the portal.
We have support offices around
the globe in Manila, Warsaw,
Chicago, and Denver, and we
support 12 different languages.
And some of the applications,
and since we've gone forward,
and they started as a
PCI compliance company,
and we've grown from there, and
we have a portfolio of services
that we offer to our
customers going forward.
And some of those are
web application firewall,
secure gateway, and
vulnerability scanning.
So enough with the
marketing side,
let's get into what the
Trustwave portal is.
So we have this portal,
we have customers
that log into our portal.
At any time, it could be up
to 40,000 unique users that
log into the portal
throughout the day,
and those users come from
customers that have security
needs that we offer to them.
And when they come
to our portal they
could be offered up one to
end different applications
within the portal framework.
So we needed a
portal that could be
customizable to the
customer's needs.
It's a common infrastructure
that we have of UI components
with backing Java services,
and within the portal
there's 35 different
applications
that could be loaded.
Now, for our normal
customer it'd
be like close to one to
six different applications,
but down below you see my
login, which is more support,
and we offer up
more applications
that they could get into.
So my user, when I logged in,
up at the top in the header
are separate applications
that are loaded on demand when
you click on them, and
they come into the portal,
and are loaded.
We have 12 distributed
application teams
that build out these
35 application modules.
So you can imagine
we needed a need
for a good framework for them
to be able to develop in.
So what does that portal
framework look like today?
What do we use for
this portal framework?
Well, the front end, the
portal UI that we built out
is all built out within Flex.
It consists of UI
components, modules,
and I'll speak about modules
within Flex in a minute,
and the remote calls and
serialization using BlazeDS
to our backend services.
So Flex was fantastic for us.
It's been fantastic
for us for a long time.
It's proven language within
ActionScript and with an XML
markup, it's really easy
to build UI components
very quickly.
It's very nice for
Java developers
even on the backend can actually
get into the UI that sometimes
don't like developing the
UI, but they pick up Flex
very easily, because you can
see with an XML markup what
your components
going to look like.
So it's not like you're just
playing within JavaScript
and the Dom and manipulating
and then seeing what it renders.
You can actually see it
through the markup language.
Flex has a vast UI
component library,
so we've taken advantage
of all the components
that brought along with Flex
like data grids, and drop
downs, and the buttons.
We've also grown that component.
So it's very easily within Flex
to build your own custom UI
components.
And then we took advantage
on the backend with BlazeDS.
BlazeDS allows us to do remote
calls to existing Java services
that we have on the backend.
And all our Java services
are built out within Spring.
So the portal
framework gives you
the ancillary services you
need for building applications.
So our development
teams can concentrate
on applications they need
to build for the customer
needs, their set, and not
worry about security, session,
auditing, logging, those
other services that
are all part of the
portal framework,
and also take advantage
of the UI components
that we've built out.
So as we start
moving over this is
a graph that shows the number
of lines of code breakdown
within some of our
main application
blocks, compliant scan, and
MSS, and then we bucketed it
off the other applications.
And it's skewed to
the backend services.
We have a lot of services
on the backend that
are gathering up
information that we
need to present through the UI.
And those Java services, we're
not going to rewrite those.
We need to take advantage
of those going forward,
so as we started looking
for our new UI framework
we had to make sure
that we accomplished
certain needs to make sure that
we took advantage of the Java
service on the backend.
The front end, it's
ActionScript and MXML.
That's all going
to be rewritten,
so you can get an
idea from the graph
here some of the
ActionScript and MXML
that's going to be ported over.
And it's not going to
be just a direct port.
We're doing a rethinking
of some of these apps,
and how it should be presented
in the portal going forward.
So it's a great
opportunity for us
as we start porting, start
rethinking some of our UI/UX
decisions that we made in
the past, learn from them,
and do it better within Dart.
So why are we moving
away from Flex?
It's been great for us.
We chose it back in 2007,
because it was at a time
that it was great and quick
to build out applications.
But now with Flash is
there's the decreasing vendor
interest within having a
Flash Player out there.
And right now, you don't have
to use a Flash Player anymore
to take advantage of
things that are now
you can do through HTML5.
So you can get a rich internet
application experience
without actually using a Flash
Player within the browser
like you had to do in the
past back in the late 2000s.
There's also been a change
in the browser landscape
that we really want to
take advantage of now.
With web components coming up
big time within the industry
we want to start taking
advantage of that now,
and this is a good time for
us, because you can actually
build out element tags,
and build them out.
And it's going to have the same
feel that you have within Flex
when you're doing
a markup language,
now you can do that
within HTML, and that's
a gradual, easy change
for our developers going
into a new language.
Flex is not a good
solution for mobile,
and you can't load a Flash
Player on any mobile browser
out there today that's going
to do anything for you,
so as a company as we start
looking to go forward and have
a mobile solution,
this is a good time
to get off of Flex and Flash,
and start going forward
as a company in thinking
about how we want to present
the information to our users.
And this is a
great chance for us
to get productivity
from our developers.
Right now, it's coming up soon,
I'll talk about our experience
within Dart Editor, and it
hasn't been a good experience
so far for our
developers within Flash,
and now going
forward within Dart,
we're going to have
great productivity
from our developers.
So it was about two years
ago, we're out at Adobe MAX,
and Flex is really not
being talked about as much
in the past.
It was about two
or three years ago,
I can't get my timing right.
Time flies.
But we'd start asking
questions, the presentations
weren't as big, and we'd gone
to the event for two years,
and this was our third year.
So we knew something
was going on,
and it was right after the
event they all of a sudden said,
all right, Flex is
out of our boat.
We're going to open
source with it,
and Flash Player's
going away, so it
started making us think,
OK, what's next for us?
We got to start going
for newer technologies.
So the one thing
that back in 2007
when we decide to
go with Flex, it
was great, because we didn't
want to jump into JavaScript.
When we have that many
12 developer teams,
I can only imagine all of
them designing all their code
in JavaScript, and
bringing it together
at run time and what spaghetti
code that would create.
So Dart was a great framework
for us to choose going forward,
and the first thing that
we thought about in Q4
was looking at Angular
for our framework,
and Polymer for
our UI components.
Polymer has a great set of
the core and paper elements
that we could take advantage of.
And when we started doing
this in quarter four,
these were the goals
that we're looking for.
We wanted to make sure we had
a good development environment,
we had support for
current Spring services
going forward because
we've got to take advantage
of all those services
that we have,
we want to make
sure that we have
a framework for building
those portal modules that
are loaded in.
And I forgot to touch
on this earlier,
and I'm going to
touch on it now,
but within Flex, they have
a concept of a module.
That module can be
loaded in at run time.
It's a SWF file.
So all those applications
that you saw on our portal
at the top those were
loaded in at run time when
you clicked on those modules.
The SWF was brought in, and it
would appear within the app.
So it allowed our developers
to work on those independently
of our portal framework,
which sped it up a lot,
so going forward we want
to make sure we can still
do that going forward.
And we want to make sure we
can support our existing Flex
modules in the Dart
portal going forward,
because we have 35 of them.
We can't port them all at once.
It's going to take some time.
So the common
development environment.
With the use of
Dart Editor, we have
seen great productivity going
forward for our developers.
The graph on the right
shows within Flash Builder
that we were using within
Eclipse building out
a module that they were building
and loading into our portal.
During development
time, the compile time
was close to two
minutes, and that's
being on the median edge.
We have some are bigger
applications that
were taking close to
three to four minutes
before you could actually
see what was happening
within your application.
Incremental updates
were at 90 seconds.
So it wasn't any quicker after
you had your server running
and then make a change and then
publish it out to your server.
So this was really
decreasing productivity
from our developers, because
all developers at times has ADD,
and all a sudden,
you're just waiting,
you're looking at your phone,
you're looking at email,
and then you forget what
you're actually working on it.
So Dart, it's fantastic.
These times are for
before we started
using Polymer and Angular,
and our compile times
and incremental updates.
So now you can actually make
a change in the Dart Editor,
first time the pub
server starts up,
that's your time that it takes,
but the incremental updates
are instantaneous, and
you can see your changes.
And for building out UIs, this
is a really, really key part
of building out your
UIs because you want
to see your changes right away.
We're still going
forward with Eclipse
right now for our development
four our Java services.
So right now, we have
a mixed environment,
but with IntelliJ going forward
that's probably the next step
that we'll go to
that we could have
a mixed environment for building
out these UI and the services.
Serialization within Dart.
So we needed to
still take advantage
of our backend services,
so this is the same slide
that I showed earlier, but we're
changing out our technologies
that are used here.
So now the portal UI is going
to be built out within Dart.
But how are we going to
call those backend services?
How are we going to still
have that same remoting
and that same feel
for our developers
as they're coding out, calling
their backend services?
Well, what we did is we built
out a layer within Dart that
supports an RPC-style
service endpoints,
and it uses our existing session
mechanism that we have today.
So we have a session that goes
down on every service calling.
All of our backend Java
services, remoted services
on the backend are all
protected as well by sessions
so we have to make sure we
handle that mechanism going
forward.
And everything is serialized
from the Dart models,
our objects that we
have on the front end,
to JSON to our backend services.
And then on the backend, we
built a layer within Java
that's going to
actually translate
that JSON into our
Java objects, and then
be able to call our
backend services.
So you get the feel within
Dart that you're actually
calling a service
that's within Dart,
but it's actually remoting
to your backend service,
so it's been fantastic.
One of things that we
use on the portal UI side
is we use the SourceGen
library that I'm going
to talk about in a minute.
Thanks to Kevin Moore
who built that library,
and it's been fantastic for us.
And on the backend
services, we're
having direct mapping from our
Dart objects to our Java types.
Here's a little bit of a sample
code of our simple user class.
And I left out a little
bit of the middle,
because we didn't want to have
all the values going down.
So one of the complaints
when we were in Flex
is having to do boilerplate
code over and over again.
We used what was called
Cairngorm within Flex
back in the day,
and you had to have
so many different classes
for making one service
call to the backend.
And developers hate to
always create those classes
over and over and over again.
They're copying and pasting,
just creating the class.
We wanted to get rid of that.
And one of the things
that we have where we're
taking a [INAUDIBLE] Dart
object that we've created,
and we want to actually
serialize to the backend,
you have to usually build
out two different methods
for to JSON and from JSON.
So you could have the
serialization going back
from the JSON on
the communication.
We didn't want to have
to have developers always
doing the translations
in these model objects,
because that's a waste of time.
So by using the
SourceGen projects
we're able to
annotate our classes,
do a pre-build process
that creates a part file,
and you can include that part
file within your model class,
and you get these two
functions from the part file.
It builds your
translation for you.
So now you just add two methods
for the to JSON and from JSON,
and it automatically gets
that serialization you want,
and you didn't have to actually
build out those methods.
So thank you, Kevin Moore.
That's a great library
that we take advantage of,
and it's been great for us.
And then this is an example code
of our RPC layer within Dart.
On the left side, it's
actually using the user service
within one of our module
apps that we built out
in Dart for actually
adding users to our portal.
So we're taking some of
our admin apps early on
and porting them over from Flex.
On the right side is the
implementation of the user
service class that's extending
underneath RPC service class,
and it allows you to
do invokes on methods
on the backend that are actually
tied to a Spring service.
So when someone uses
the user service,
they don't care
where it's calling,
what URL backend it's going
to that can switch up on them.
They're just guaranteed
on the front end
that when I create a user
and I say create user,
I'm going to create a user,
and it returns a future.
So on that side there's
nothing on the return of it
so they just went
on on their way.
But on the bottom side we
take advantage of async await.
So this is really nice
for our developers.
Instead of within Flex,
we've been doing callbacks
after callbacks after callbacks
after callbacks chaining them
along, and it's
a lot easier when
you can actually see your
code synchronously going down.
So going forward it
calls the find all users.
Right here when it passes down
this method within the JSON
it actually puts the
method name you're
calling on the backend
service so it knows
how to translate that through.
Put an await on it, and
you've got your return back
synchronously.
You don't have to have callback
after callback after callback.
Async await has been a
great feature in Dart
that we've been looking
forward to take advantage of
and our engineers
really like it.
Portal UI modules.
So within Flex, our
application teams
can build modules out, and
then bring it in at run time.
It's been a fantastic
feature for us.
It allows them to develop
on their own independent
of the portal framework.
Going forward, we need that same
type of concept going forward,
so we started looking at
Angular Dart for our framework.
That was the first
one, and we wanted
to take advantage of the
dependency injection in it.
We look at an Angular
Dart as the framework
and Polymer as the UI components
that you can bring into it
and you mesh those two together.
So we didn't want to just
build it out on Polymer.
So our first journey
was building out
the entire framework
within Angular
and having our
development teams use it,
so we could take advantage of
the routing in Angular Dart.
And we're on Angular
Dart 1.0 right now.
And the routing is great for us
because currently in our portal
we can't take advantage of
the back and forward button.
We're in a Flash module.
We didn't build the
integration between the two
and keep track of
every screen they
were moving to
because they didn't
have anything built into it.
So basically if someone tried
to push back or forward,
we warned them,
hey, you're going
to be getting out of our site.
And that's a bad user
experience for our portal.
We want to allow them
that if they switch
through different views
they can go back and forth,
so the routing
within Angular Dart
was something we wanted
to take advantage of.
But it was lacking in
some ways within 1.0.
When we go to Views within
our rich internet application
they're stateful views that
you transition through.
In an Angular Dart
1.0 router right
now doesn't have a
concept of stateful views.
When you go through
the routes it's
a new view that's
loaded in every time
as you go through that route.
So we're looking forward
to 2.0, the specs
that are coming out
from there that they're
solving part of that problem.
That was the main problem
with it, excuse me.
The next one was the deferred
loading of applications.
So we have that right
now with module SWFs.
With Angular Dart we've been
able to accomplish this.
We have a base module that
people can extend off of,
and we do deferred loading
of that library package
within our portal
until the user clicks
on the header to load in
that module application.
So at that time, we call that
library, we say load library,
and when we know we've
loaded it in, at that point,
we bind the module from Angular,
so we can have that element
tag, and then we use an Angular
compiler to compile that view
in with that element
tag, and voila,
it's loaded asynchronously
from the backend,
and it's not there
at compile time.
So we get the same feel that
we've gotten within Flex today
with loading module
SWFs in a different way
by using the deferred
loading within Dart,
and then the Angular
library we're
able to compile in
element tags at run time.
That has been one
of the major goals
that we needed to accomplish.
It's one of the things
that we were thinking
about when we were
going to port over
to a new framework
is we still needed
to keep that concept today,
because we don't want to have
the user experience at the
beginning of our portal loading
to be cumbersome to our users.
We want it to be quick and
fast, have the tree shaking
happening from Dart to GS,
and defer load those libraries
at run time.
Now, going forward
we also within Flex,
we had a vast array
of UI components.
We had data grids, we had
drop downs, we had splitterrs,
sliders, you name it,
collapsible panels,
it was all built into
the Flex library,
and a lot of components
that we built out that
were custom to us.
So going forward it's
like what UI component
are we going to build off of?
Polymer UI has been a perfect
fit for us going forward
Polymer UI, with the
core and paper elements,
gives us all the base UI
components that we need,
and then we can
build off of them
going forward, and actually
following the web component
standard.
So we've actually gotten the
binding between Angular Dart
and Polymer working
to a point, We're
hoping going forward that
the two teams solve some
of that between the
bindings and the events,
but it's worked for us
right now going forward.
And now we have the distributed
application development
in the new portal going forward.
But as we were
going through and we
were using Angular and
Polymer we noticed something
within the Dart Editor.
The gains that we wanted to
see coming from Flex, which
we still have because the
experience within Flex
was so horrible, it was starting
to slow down the compile times
within the development
of our modules.
So we first started
off with Angular,
and we're just going to
build out all our modules
within Angular, we'll build
out UI components with Angular.
We were just staying away from
Polymer for this last quarter,
because Angular
was farther ahead,
Polymer was a little bit behind.
Well, at that time
we saw compile times
for some of our modules, bigger
modules, taking 22 seconds,
and the incremental updates
were taking around 12 seconds.
So it's way better than what
we were experiencing in Flex,
but it still wasn't
the quickness
that we wanted to see.
But then we went
through and we said,
well, Polymer's
catching up, we still
want to use Angular
for our framework,
let's use them together, let's
start bringing in the web
components from Polymer, take
advantage of the paper and core
elements.
And within the transformers that
we were seeing during dev time,
we put the Polymer transformer
first and the Angular
transformer second.
All a sudden, it jumped
up to 40 and 28 seconds,
and it was like, OK,
this is not what we want
to see during development time.
So just by chance, we
flipped the transformers
and we saw a great increase
on it between the two.
But then at that time
when we found that out,
all of a sudden Angular
2.0's coming out,
that's going to solve
a lot of our problems,
and we started building
out now, and our teams
are building out all their
views and UI components
within Polymer.
And the Polymer method
of going through it
and actual compile times and
incremental updates is great.
So our development teams
are going really fast,
developing through, building
out these UI components,
and now we're-- with
the announcement today,
which made me very happy with
the dev release of Angular
2.0-- we're going to go forward
building our portal framework
out within Angular, taking
advantage of the routing,
and be able to bring in
these web components,
and get the binding and
the events between the two
as the teams start
building them out.
The last thing of the
goals that we needed was we
need to support our existing
legacy applications that are
within Flex within the portal.
This was a big one, because
we have 35 application modules
within the portal today that
we can't port simultaneously
all at once.
So we need to have a way
that we can load those Flex
modules into our new Dart
portal Chrome portal framework.
So what we've done is we've
used the Dart JS library,
and built a JavaScript
bridge in between.
And we're doing communication
between Flex and the Flash
Player and to the Dart Chrome.
So if you remember
on that first slide,
we had the header at the top,
and we had all of our modules,
now it's a mixture.
So when a user logs into
the new portal Dart Chrome,
you could have Dart
modules up there
or you could have Flex modules.
You don't know which is
which until you click on them
and we know from just our
database as a user logged in
and what they were
provisioned to whether it's
a Dart module or a Flex module.
And at that time, if
it's a Flex module,
the stage loads just one
Flash Player, and that module
comes into it.
With the Dart module,
it swaps it out
and the Dart module comes in.
So now we have the communication
from our Dart portal
through JavaScript to
our Flex applications.
This was a big win for us.
When we showed this
to our PM department,
they were very happy
about it, because it
made our timeline now coming
up to the third quarter
this year that we can
actually accomplish building
out our framework,
our portal framework,
have new applications
coming in with Dart modules,
but keep those legacy Flex
applications going forward.
So now the timelines for other
applications being ported over
fits within what PM wants
to see going forward.
So that was a big win for us.
So what are some of the
conclusions and what's next
for us?
Well, we saw the increase
productivity with Dart Editor,
and going forward
now with Webstorm.
We have the RPC-style
calls with Dart.
We have application development
going on within Polymer right
now and Angular with
the portal framework,
and we have Dart and
Flex interoperability
with the modules
loading into our portal.
This is our new look and
feel within the portal.
Example of what we
have today, and this
is one of our Dart modules,
how it looks loading into it.
So going forward now today, it
was users, what's been ported,
it would be like assets
if it was a Flex module,
it would load with
into this stage area
and have that interoperability
between the two.
The one thing that we're
still concentrating on
on the Flex side is we've got to
change a little bit of the look
and feel to match
what we have here
so we don't see any clunkiness
for our users coming
into the portal.
We have multiple development
teams working on applications
right now.
A lot of them are
early adopters and also
new applications
we're building out.
We're not going to be
doing that within Flex,
but we're doing that
within Dart, Angular Dart,
and Polymer.
And we're really
excited about 2.0.
And 1.0, I put this on the slide
before I found out from Kevin
that the news on that
was coming forward.
So we're looking for
stability between those two,
so we can take advantage of
some of the new functionality
especially within the
routing within Angular 2.0.
So thank you very much.
I'm going to be here throughout
the rest of the summit.
If anybody wants to talk
about our experience and some
of the stuff we did, and I can
show a little bit more code
than I showed on
the slides today.
It's hard to condense
it within 30 minutes.
And also, I'd love
to hear about any
of your experiences you have
as well with using Angular Dart
or Polymer.
So thank you very much.
MALE SPEAKER: Do you want
to do some questions?
ERIC WOERNER: Sure.
MALE SPEAKER: We have time.
ERIC WOERNER: Yeah, let's do it.
MALE SPEAKER: 5, 10
minutes actually.
We were so afraid
that you guys wouldn't
be able to fit
into the timeframe
that we were like you
got to cut it down.
ERIC WOERNER: You guys
coached us very well.
MALE SPEAKER: Apparently,
we over-coached you,
because everyone's
doing like 20 minutes.
There's time for questions.
Anyone?
ERIC WOERNER: Fire away.
MALE SPEAKER: As a bonus,
I will awkwardly run to you
to hand you a microphone.
AUDIENCE: Just
wanted to know I saw
I think the same thing that
you saw with the Angular
and Polymer times.
And so what is it that
you said that you'd
switched the [INAUDIBLE]
to the Polymers first?
ERIC WOERNER: We first had,
we had the Polymer first.
AUDIENCE: You started
with Angular first.
ERIC WOERNER: Hold on.
Let me check my
slide real quick.
AUDIENCE: I've got Angular first
and I've got the slow times.
ERIC WOERNER: It was
Polymer first, then Angular.
Flip it.
I saw it much increase time
going that way that it.
AUDIENCE: And have you
tried it with Angular 2.0?
ERIC WOERNER: In
my head, I don't
know for sure, been looking
over the transformers,
my thinking on it is whatever
happens with the Polymer
and all of a sudden it gets
to the Angular transformer
afterwards causes Angular
to go a little bit longer.
AUDIENCE: OK.
That was illuminating.
Thanks.
ERIC WOERNER: You bet.
MALE SPEAKER: Anyone else?
ERIC WOERNER: All right.
MALE SPEAKER: Going, going.
AUDIENCE: So I was curious,
Polymer and Angular
both have an overlapping
feature set when it comes
to binding and some UI stuff.
I'm wondering what is it
that Angular is giving you
that Polymer is not?
ERIC WOERNER: I
look at Angular as
with the dependency
injection, the routing that's
involved in it as
the framework we
want to use for building
out, for switching
between our modules,
switching between our views,
using the deferred loading,
bringing in the element
tags, and the compile
time at that point.
I look at Polymer as I want
to build a new data grid.
I want to build a
UI component that I
want to share with
other application teams
within the portal.
We'll build them all
out within Polymer
and they can bring that
within an Angular Dart view
or within another Polymer view.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ERIC WOERNER: You bet.
MALE SPEAKER: Anyone else?
Think we have time for one more.
Yes?
No?
OK.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I was curious.
I can ask without
the microphone.
If you weren't
going to use Dart,
what else were you looking
at, because obviously
the things moving forward,
but where else would you go?
ERIC WOERNER: We looked
at TypeScript, CopyScript,
and then it just
goes into all the JS
libraries that are out there.
For building something
like this where
we have 12 distributed
teams, and it gave me
nightmares to think that they
would be developing everything
within JavaScript, and
bringing that all together.
MALE SPEAKER 2: But with
Bob, you sleep well at night?
ERIC WOERNER: Much, much better.
Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER 2: And
the whole Dart team.
I didn't want to imply anything.
ERIC WOERNER: No,
the whole Dart.
It's been a
fantastic experience.
We started, it was like two
years ago when we came back,
and Larry Podmolik, our CTO,
put together a little training
exercise for all the teams.
And we had about 45 development
staff on the portal development
team at that time, and it was
just a command line app calling
out to a little WebSocket
bringing back information,
and everybody got so
excited about using Dart,
and then it's just
blossomed from there.
So it's been fantastic.
But we still have, every
once in awhile, you
have those JavaScript
purists, and it's
like, why don't use you
Bootstrap and Backbone,
and build it from there?
But it's like, do you
understand the portal framework
we're trying to build?
We can't build it with
just those two tools.
MALE SPEAKER 2:
You convinced me.
ERIC WOERNER: Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER 2:
Thank you so much.
ERIC WOERNER: You bet.
MALE SPEAKER 2: Thanks, Eric.
ERIC WOERNER: Thank you.